it is a great time to be a fan of
Resident Evil specifically Resident Evil
Village because there is new DLC on the
way yes Winters is coming
um specifically Ethan winners and his
daughter Rose Winters we went down to
Capcom recently John Luke and I and we
played some of the Rose DLC
um what's the official title of it John
Luke uh shadow of rose and it was an
interesting experience a lot of familiar
stuff but also a lot of unfamiliar stuff
or familiar stuff from the perspective
of the unfamiliar uh what did you think
of it first of all uh I am surprised how
much I liked it you know I wasn't really
sure if I wanted more Resident Evil
Village I love that game but I was like
I'm kind of done with it um and it's
been like so long since they've done any
DLC like my brain is already like
squarely focused on Resident Evil 4
remake at this point but uh I do think
playing this was like oh yeah you know
what this will be a nice little thing to
play to hold me over
four uh for remake and uh yeah I mean
you know it's a DLC so as we kind of
will get into it's not gonna be game
changing or anything but I think they're
doing a couple of kind of interesting
things to sort of keep it fresh from the
base game
um reusing environments uh you know so
yeah I'm uh I'm looking forward to it I
think that that's gonna be the elephant
in the room in a lot of ways and it's
gonna be the thing that people really
latch onto is the ReUse of the
environment
um and
it is the section we played was pretty
much one for one Castle dimitrisk
um and uh what you're kind of you're
inside the meta my seat which you may
have forgotten from Resident Evil seven
and eight yeah but it's definitely an
important part of the Resident Evil
Ethan Winter's Arc uh story but so what
they've done is
they've kind of metroidvania the entire
environment even more so than a Resident
Evil game would ordinarily be but um the
other main thing is you're now seeing it
from a Brand New Perspective Third
person right
um do you think that did anything to
kind of alleviate the uh sameness or the
familiarity that
um you would ordinarily feel from
reusing environments I would say so you
know it was it was nice kind of playing
it in that third person perspective you
get to kind of like reappreciate how it
looks it's also been a year since uh
that game came out so for me it was like
nice to go and revisit it
um but it was cool that they kind of
decided to go with third person you can
only play in third person there is no
option for first person
and it pretty much behaves exactly like
Resident Evil uh two and three remake in
terms of just like how Rose feels to
control also uh in terms of how the
enemies work uh there's these very
specific new enemies called
um the like face face Steelers face what
was it face face munchers face eaters
you wrote face munchers the official
name is face eaters I was close you were
very close yeah this is when I say we
wrote it like I was writing notes before
they had told us much about it and I
wrote like face munchers as a joke and
they were like face dealers and I was
like oh so close
yeah so the the face eaters are like the
new enemy types uh that are kind of like
chasing Rose around and if they grab you
they well they eat her face uh and
they're they they're nice and creepy
looking
um they don't like eat your face as in
Resident Evil zombie style it's that's
the interesting thing they like they're
like they're sucking out since yeah yeah
they're like eating your soul they're
like they're like slurping your soul
yeah if you like go frame by frame it
actually looks really like disturbing
and weird like her face is like being
slowly like absorbed
but you mentioned Resident Evil zombies
and what's interesting is it feels like
they actually took a lot of like the way
the um zombies in two and three remake
worked and kind of like use them as the
base for the face eaters so uh kind of
like you know uh the the way they
shamble and and the way you can uh they
wait like the way they fall over and die
and you can kind of like shoot them in
the leg to stun them so it seems like
they're kind of you know smartly reusing
resources to sort of like okay well
we'll take a a familiar enemy type from
those games and kind of like uh kind of
put a Twist on them for this but it
feels fresh here because like there
weren't zombies in
um village so like you kind of are
getting this interesting like they're
taking mechanics from like two and three
and they're kind of like planting them
into like a village setting
yeah um and the thing that like you said
mixes it up and and makes it a little
fresher is one the perspective which is
third person it feels like a a different
game because you're not used to seeing
like the castle from that angle and kind
of moving around it in that way Rose is
not as nippy as you might find Leon or
like Claire or anywhere anyone else to
OG oh sorry uh to be in in two and three
remake
um but she does kind of like you have a
little more awareness situational
awareness which means they have to like
rethink the way they Place enemies and
how they kind of intersect with you it's
more a case of like you know uh zombies
casually stumbling around corners like
drunks on it on on a late night like
you're like oh [ __ ] and you can back up
get away from this and then find my
space and then kind of go for them um
which which I think is is is like a good
way to mix up how that castle feels
again yeah the other thing that they're
doing to mix things up in a major way is
they're using Rose's Powers right
um what do you think of that yeah so
they like rose has like her different
powers and they're they've used them in
two ways one in like a puzzle element
and then one in a combat element uh from
what we played so far and with the
puzzle stuff basically as you're
wandering through the castle there's
like all this like goop that's sort of
blocking your path
um that's kind of like the metroidvania
element of it because
um when you get her power you can use
um the this like ability to destroy
these like little flower buds that will
then eliminate the goop and let you move
on so that's kind of like the way
they're they're sort of like having you
like oh now I can go back to the
beginning of the uh castle and all these
areas were suddenly opened up for me
um which is cool and you know they're I
think they do a fun job of kind of like
remixing the order in which you're
exploring the castle versus how it was
uh in the base game so that's nice the
other element is that you can use the
powers to actually uh stun enemies which
is interesting so um you they'll
basically uh not entirely freeze them
they kind of they're like slow motion
right like they like they move very
slowly
um and I know that we both kind of did
it differently where I was using it as a
tactic to
escape a bunch of enemies I was in a
room with like three of them and I
didn't have enough bullets so I just
like popped one of my my kind of like
freezing powers to sort of get away from
them uh where you kind of more used it
as like a tool to uh like more
accurately like take them down I use it
as like a way to increase my Precision
like my my version of ammo conservation
was like
make every shot count and that really
helped
so there's definitely some strategy some
mileage to be had from those two power
those Powers basically
um
this I imagine more stuff that you'll be
able to do going on right um we had just
in our demo we only had access to that
um and there was definitely like without
spoiling too much there were definitely
situations where it was like I
definitely need to freeze that enemy
because they have like enemy types that
are unique and new yeah
um and definitely immediately pose a
much greater threat in any standard face
stealing munching slurping kinds
um the other thing I wanted to talk
about briefly is uh we talked about the
metamyc and you're kind of like
re-experiencing Castle dimitrisk but
um the Duke is also back in this which
is well it's he looks like the Duke but
it doesn't seem to be the Duke because
the Duke was very friendly to us yeah in
village and this Duke is not being
friendly at all no no he is yeah it's
probably not him because of like the
nature of sort of like you're not in
like reality
um but yeah he had like this creepy mask
on and
um you know seemed to be like hunting
people down
um he used like what he described as
like hunting like rabbits is what he
said uh I think he makes multiple like
Alice in Wonderland down down the rabbit
hole references as well I I don't know
if I imagined that or if he definitely
did that that seems like something they
would do yeah yeah so um yeah there's
that's that's an interesting kind of
like Twist on that as well like reusing
the Duke and making him a little more
prominent as a villain character and he
appears in as you like move around the
the kind of um the castle in the Joker
on the TV screen form but it's literally
him his face on a TV screen right you
wander down and he's like taunting you
or or telling you he's gonna get you
um so that kind of opens the door for
bringing back to these corrupted as I
like to call them versions of other
characters or meta my seat versions of
other characters like what will the
sisters or demetrisk or or any of the
other Lords how what would they look
like in this in this kind of like world
yeah I'm excited to see a bit more of
that as well
um but yeah I I was very surprised by a
lot of what I saw there's the basic
stuff that you you expect from Resident
Evil where it's like you know figure out
how to navigate these puzzles
um you know Find a bolt cutter and do it
use it for XYZ thing right and then the
metroidvania stuff where it's like uh it
ties into her powers where it's like you
use the powers to shoot these you know
uh flower buds that are like uh spewing
out this toxic sludge that you can't get
past and accessing new parts of the
castle because of that and
it feels like a familiar game but like
mixed up in a comforting way if you know
what I mean like you feel like oh I
remember this game I enjoyed this game
but it feels like a fresh perspective on
it totally um yeah I think it helps that
the game has been out for a while now so
it's sort of like they're coming back to
it you're getting like a nice little uh
like story DLC
um that's gonna you know expand upon the
ending maybe it's even gonna set up
stuff for like an eventual Resident Evil
9 and uh hopefully like a nice little
holdover before
um you know Resident Evil 4 remake comes
out next year so yeah you know nothing
like uh a mind-blowing necessarily you
know it is at the end of the day a DLC
that's kind of like wheezing
um you know areas and stuff from the
game but I found myself quite enjoying
it it's like yeah I could totally go for
some more Resident Evil so um I'm
definitely gonna check it out
okay I'm gonna check out and you'll be
able to check it out later this year
when it is available uh on your platform
of choice John Luke thank you for
joining me to chat about Resident Evil
um and for more Resident Evil related
content Resident Evil 8 for remake old
Resident Evils new Resident Evils keep
it locked in GameSpot foreign